What's going on? Alan Drau here and in
today's video, I'm going to be showing
you the copywriter, how to use AI to do
market research in just 15 minutes. I'm
really excited about today's video
because I used this process for the
first time just a couple days ago,
working with my good friend Ben Fidman
for a client that we had a really tight
deadline on, which squeezed the amount
of time that we could do for market
research. He put together a bunch of AI
prompts that actually did a ton of
really good market research for me to
write the copy for this client. And so,
we're going to do it together. I'm going
to redo it live with you. I'm going to
show you the prompts. I'm going to show
you the outputs that actually came. And
I'm going to give you everything for
free. So, first off, check the link in
the descriptions below for the actual
prompts themselves. and make sure to go
over to Ben Fitterman's YouTube channel
because he is the mastermind behind
these prompts that really helped me use
this process to write great copy. All
right, so no dillydally. I've got my
coffee. I've got my prompts. We're going
to go ahead and start working together.
I'm going to share my screen. This is
going to be like a live workshop, a free
workshop. Before we dive in, let me
clarify the goal of market research if
you're unaware. So the very simple way
to think about market research is you
have a product and you have a market and
the goal is to get a product market fit.
Okay, what we're trying to dissect from
the market is what is the biggest
problem they're trying to solve? Why
have they not solve that problem?
Everything is about the problem. Okay,
their pain in solving that problem.
That's really what we're trying to
figure out. And then on the product
side, how does our product that we're
trying to sell solve that problem?
Problem to solution fit. That's it.
Well, let's dive in. Let me share my
screen and let's start working through
this market research. All right. So, you
see my screen and on my screen, my good
friend Ben has put this stuff together.
He is the mastermind behind this, but
I'm going to show you how to do it. I'm
going to give you everything that we're
doing. Okay. So, I think this is
absolutely genius. We're going to do it
live with a client that we are literally
writing for right now. So, we're working
for a client right now called Delight
Station. And what DelightStation is is
they are a video streaming service for
adults with disabilities. Okay? So,
adults with disabilities have uh
different problems and challenges as far
as video streaming services. They can't
really use YouTube or Netflix or
anything like that cuz it's it's not
really appropriate to what they watch.
It doesn't teach them anything. It's
usually junk. As well as it's it's tough
to navigate. they could be navigating
YouTube and all kinds of other problems
that leads them down a hole. So, it's a
big market, big problem. And so, what
we're trying to do in this video is try
to learn more about the parents and the
caregivers of those adults with
disabilities because those are the
people that we are trying to reach. This
is their current website uh that we are
rewriting and we're rewriting some
emails for them. Okay, so really, really
cool. So, let's go back to our document
here. And in our document, we have a
series of steps that we're going to be
doing. Okay. So, I'm going to come in
here and I'm going to go to chat GPT and
I'm going to start a new chat right
here. Copy and paste the context for
each one of these steps and we're going
to do it live. Okay. So, step zero is
we're going to do a rapid market
snapshot. And in this, we're just trying
to get a nice overview so we fully
understand the market itself in an
instance. And everything that we prompt,
we're going to move over to a document
here in a second. Okay. So, I'm going to
take this. Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
The rapid market screenshot. And I'm
going to copy this and I'm going to move
it over to ChachiBT. Okay. Get out of
here, Grammarly. Idiot. Why are you
here? Okay. All right. So, it needs a
little finangling. No problem. My ideal
customer persona is parent or caregiver
of adults with disabilities. Okay. So,
just like I mean top we're top of the
moon here. This is not specific. I'm
like you're doing my market research,
not me. Okay. The product I want to sell
is I'm going to put the URL in.
Delightstation US. Okay. So, this is
what I'm trying to sell. I'm trying to
sell Delightstation US, which is a
streaming video service like Netflix,
but specifically for adults with
disabilities. Okay. Fantastic. And the
product that my problem is solving is
helps adults with disabilities
learn independence skills. That's the
problem that they solve. And it helps
the parents
caregivers
get a break. Okay. Which is a big big
thing in this industry. Now granted that
was some preliminary research of just
like reading the website, understanding
the product. Yeah. take five minutes to
understand the product for a second,
right? Like just kind of get like, okay,
who are the people kind of and then what
what is the problem that it's trying to
solve? Okay, got it. Like you take that
and you're rocking and rolling. Okay, so
I'm going to hit enter. Boom. Okay, so
it's got all this stuff and Chad GBT is
like, let's get to work, baby. And now
we have a really good snapshot, which
I'm going to take over here. I'm going
to copy this and I'm going to go over to
my market research doc and I'm going to
hit the snapshot section. Okay, that's
the snapshot. Bada bing, bada boom,
we're in the snapshot. What we're going
to do next is we're going to do deep
research. Okay, so for step one, we are
trying to figure out what people are
saying. So now we're trying to
understand what the market is actually
saying. All right, so now let's go in
here. We're going to copy and paste this
in here. Here's what I wanted to do.
Okay. Wanted to do step-by-step process
to get all the insights, all this stuff.
And I wanted to give me authentic quotes
in fears, frustrations, wants, beliefs,
and joys. Cite the sources on Reddit. So
that way we have the links if we want to
go do a deeper dive into it later.
Summarize these findings into quotes,
all that stuff. And then make the
results as clear, organized as possible.
Okay, we should be doing deep research
for this. Okay, let me see if I can do
deep research. Where's the tools? Run
deep research. Bam. Okay, here we go.
So, now we're going to do it and click
do the dirty work for us. Great. I'll
collect 100 quotes and it's going to
start doing the research. What? Let's go
ahead and fast forward into real life
and then see what happens from here. A
few moments later. 2,000 years later.
One eternity later. All right, we are
back. That took about 10 15 minutes to
do it. So I gave you a break in doing
that. Now look at this. We've got this
enormous document. Okay. From chatbt
that got all these threads. I mean this
is like a gold mine. Look at this. Fear
of unknown future. I am utterly
terrified. I'm effing scared. Wow.
That's incredible. Like there are so
many things. A lot of the fears of
whatifs that may never happen. Autism
parenting. I feel like a terrible
mother. Some days I wonder if all the
stress is going to do me in.
Look at this stuff. I mean, this is
like, wow. This is like a copywriter's
dream uh to be able to look at this and
be able to help. So, now I'm going to
take all this, okay? And I've got
everything. I've got hundreds of quotes
in here or 100 quotes. I'm going to take
these and I'm going to copy them over to
my market research doc. Okay. Bada bing,
bada boom. So, look at this. I mean,
this is a gold mine of market research.
Okay. So, now that we've got that part
done, step one in the deep research.
Now, we're going to do the psychoraphic
research. We're going to understand more
about our ideal clients. Okay? So, I'm
going to copy and paste this thing right
here. Boom, boom, boom, boom. I'm going
to take this. I'm going to come over
here. We don't have to do deep research
for this one, but I'm going to hit boom.
Now, we're organizing not just the
quotes, but now we're pairing them into
actual buckets to use for our
copywriting here in just a minute.
identity problems, physical and
emotional burnout, isolation and
loneliness, obstacles. Oh my gosh, this
is this is a gem. This is a I can't
believe I'm giving this to you for free.
This is wild. Okay, so I'm going to take
all this and then I'm going to copy that
over to our doc. Bam. Okay, so now it
knows all of this stuff about us. So now
we're going to keep on rolling and we're
going to do market awareness levels and
market desire tables. So, we're going to
do over here. We're going to copy and
paste this. Here's what I'm trying to
find out. Market awareness through the
Eugene Schwarz lens. Building a table,
five columns, most aware, product aware,
solution aware, problem aware, unaware,
all that stuff. Right? It's I'm telling
it to make columns and then I'm telling
it to go a little bit deeper. Find five
to 10 explicit desires and then create
the so I can go deeper on each desire so
we can dimensionalize the benefits,
problems, solutions, all that stuff. And
then we tell it all the tables, quality
check, market output exactly how we do
it. And then bam, we tell it to keep the
formatting clean. Look at this. Oh my
goodness. What is it doing? Why is this
so cool? Look at this. This is
incredible. This is abs. This is my mind
is
I'm going to take that. I'm going to put
it into our dock right down here at the
bottom. Boom. Okay. So now we've got it
pretty clean in here. Good enough,
right? So we actually understand what's
going on in here. And then we're going
to take the final step. Now we're going
to understand how we're going to
actually tie this all together. Okay. So
I'm going to take that. Okay. So the
goal here is to reveal and
dimensionalize every meaningful feature
of the product and translate it into
hard and layered benefits that resonate
on a practical, emotional, and desire
level using the Eugene Schwarz classic
research lens. So now what we have is we
have a feature to benefit table. Here we
go, baby. All right. So that's going to
come in here. We're going to put that
bam in there. And it's actually telling
us everything that we need to know for
the product name, what the feature, what
uh what the feature includes, what's the
performance benefit so you can do what?
What's the benefit of the benefit? Okay,
one layer deeper. What's the dominant
emotion that claim makepiece vibe? And
then what's the matching desire? Look at
this. So now we have done our market
research in less than 15 minutes.
Rocking and rolling. We have this entire
19page document to help us write the
copy. The next thing I like to do is I
like to go to Claude. Okay. I like to go
to Claude because I think Claude is a
better writer uh than Chat GBT,
especially if you're working on a quick
project. And I'm going to come in here
and what I'm going to do is I'm going to
download this document as a uh rich text
format. The reason I do a rich text
format instead of like a PDF is I should
have named the document, but it is what
it is. Uh is because it reads text
better. So I'm going to come in here and
I'm going to upload the file
untitled idiot. And I'm going to come in
here and say here is a document for a
client that I am rewriting a landing
page copy for. Rewriting the landing
page copy for here is the research
document.
I want you to outline the landing page
copy for me. This is like not a fancy
prompt by any means. All I'm trying to
do is take the market research and start
prepping ideas. Okay? I'm just prepping
ideas. I may use 10% of it. I may use
90% of it. I may use 50% of it in the
sense. But over here, look what it's
doing. It it is finally screen time that
actually helps your uh adult child grow.
Not the best headline by any means, but
it's giving me an idea. Okay, I
understand how they're going. Like you
want the child to grow. I'm probably
going to say something about
independence. I'm going to talk about
burnout. I'm going to talk about taking
a break just based on the market
research, but at least I have somewhere
to start. Okay? At least I have
somewhere to be like, "Okay, here's the
key differentiators. Got it. Here's the
solution problem agitation section."
Okay, good to know. All right. And a lot
of time, here's what I'll do is I'll
actually copy this. I'll come in there.
I'll do a new tab and I'll do landing
page outline. Okay, just so I have
something. And bam. Okay, you got
something here. And then I got the
market research. I got the landing page
outline. And then what I'll do is final
copy. And then from there, I'll actually
start taking stuff from each page and
building my own landing page based on
the research, based on the claude and
all of these things. So that way I could
do a much better job writing copy. So
those are the prompts. That is a quick
and dirty way to do market research.
It's actually pretty incredible.
Personally, if you're getting nice and
high paid chunky checks, I still
recommend talking to the market and
things like that. But honestly, for 80%
of the clients that you're going to do
work with, this method of market
research is absolutely incredible.
Absolutely incredible. I hope it's
helpful to you. If you enjoyed today's
videos, gosh, please do me a big favor.
Like the video and subscribe to the
channel. That tells me that you want me
to make more free content just like
this. And again, if you want these
prompts, you could go ahead. They're in
the link in the description below. You
can grab them for free. Just put your
email. It'll automatically send to you.
And then you get the prompts. you can
use them for your next client.
Hopefully, it makes you a lot of money
and I help you as a copywriter. So, I
appreciate you. Thank you for your time
and uh and I will catch you on the next
one. Hey, actually before you leave,
okay, so you like the channel, you
subscribe to the channel. Awesome. You
are incredible. Go ahead and leave a
comment down below. What video do you
want me to make next? What is most
helpful to you? I want to be helpful to
you. So, just let me know. Drop it in
the comments. What video do you want me
to make next? And I'll make it for you.
All right, we'll chat. See you in the
next one.